welcome to this talk about philosophy of
macros in scala
uh it's it's a great pleasure for me to
to present here a stranger
who might have known so uh
today we will first take a look at the
history of macros in scala
how we got macros how it started
how it went through the release process
and how macros ended up in scala to 10
and then we'll we'll take take a small
look into the future
uh but all that it's not just just for
being cute but
for the purpose the purpose of
distilling the essence of macros and
scala so sure macros
macros and scala are very heavily
inspired by other languages
lisp for instance right but they have
but they have some unique things that i
would like to share today
and uh well that's that's the one the
main point of the presentation
so first of all how did scholar get
macros
back then when i when i was uh still in
belarus my home country
i was an enterprise c sharp developer
and
i was very excited when c sharp 3.0 came
out
you know expression trees meta
programming in in some in some way that
was
that was revelation right and i i've
since then i've been doing some uh
meta programming projects for c-sharp
for instance cross-compiler of
link queries to javascript and back and
then i did
a cross-compilation of c-sharp to cuda
but
you know it was always handwritten and
not so elegant because there's no
language support and then
cross compilation for code it was it was
really funny because
i actually had to write a bytecode
decompiler
and roll my own asts and stuff well yeah
that felt good
and uh roughly roughly at that time
period i realized that in scala
people actually can do similar stuff but
it's it's much simpler because they can
change the language and then i thought
okay
cool um it would be really great to
to join the school team and that's how i
ended up in uh at a pfl
uh the home of scala the place where it
was conceived
and uh well i started there as a phd
student and all phd students at epfl
they have to do semester projects
and so my semester project started two
years ago
in september actually two days ago it
was second anniversary
and well i just throw to the maiden list
all right let's
let's do macros well so first
at first at first it was just a fun
project
and uh it was heavily inspired by
nemmerle maybe you know this language
that net language that has macros but
then
but then it's it rapidly escalated
because macro suddenly became necessary
for
for an industrial project and that was a
very interesting transition
so what what project i'm talking about
well actually there's this thing called
slick a joint
product of epfl and typesafe and silica
is is basically
a database connectivity kit
for for scala applications so the idea
was to to have
queries integrated into language so that
people could
could do stuff like this so you write
queries in normal scholar without any
dsls and stuff
and then these queries get transparently
translated to
awesome data structures the main
specific data structures
well it's all very cool and link you did
that
by by this expression trees by type
directed lifting
of of code and
well yeah this this is how folks were
going to do that
and then i realized macros and
really macros people macros and
and then sort of i went through
everything that i knew about macros from
emerald from template haskell from from
scheme racket
and then i came to martin martin odersky
uh my professor and also creator of
scala
with this with something like this so i
told martin luke
there's such thing as macros and they
can implement link
and with macros you can essentially
write methods that are executed at
compile time
and these methods can generate code and
then this code
well can be used as usual as if the
programmer has written this code
him or her herself and uh
well it was it was kind of cool when i
did this presentation at the lab meeting
people were more or less excited and
then i started explaining all this stuff
that macros
do compile time function execution well
essentially you write normal scalar
functions and they get executed at
compile time but
by the compiler itself and then
well macros you can write quasi quo so
this
these things in fact infancy brackets
these are quasi codes steady code
templates
that you can uh insert things into
dynamic things into using dollars
so it's just just a lot very similar to
to template languages or to bash
and then this quasi-calls these
quasi-calls are hygienic because look
here we
create queries and variables and stuff
but this code is actually
is not going to be executed here macros
are going to expand somewhere else
so someone calls calls filter oh
by the way here here's the convention
that i'm going to follow in the
presentation so
everything macro related is going to be
in blue so this this filter call is
actually a macro
so when someone calls this filter the
function gets executed this macro dev
and then the result gets inserted at the
call side
so everything that we see here creation
of queryable filter and
all these fancy astinos it's all going
to move
from from the definition of the macro to
the invocation
okay so here's here so where we
meet hygiene so in in this in
in this code implicit is the
understanding of the programmer of the
macro programmer that
if you're if you say import some
identifier here for example query or
filter
then it's going to mean the same when it
gets into the call side
of the macro so you write stuff here
it ends up here and it means exactly the
same
so more or less this is the idea of
hygiene
and uh well since we can have macro devs
how about we we have macro classes how
about generating classes with macros
how about having macro packages and
stuff you know all these fancy things
and as i was elaborating through my
presentation
on this lab meeting i i saw martin
having this expression oh yeah really
interesting
and i i i couldn't understand that
because look i'm
i'm talking about this fancy stuff it's
so exciting look quasi quotes hygiene oh
my god and
all that in scala but
some something was clearly wrong and uh
well
now in hindsight that's quite obvious
but but well look
so i just wanted to introduce a single
language feature and then brings a lot
of friends
and well scalab
by that time scala was almost 10 years
old it
has quite a number of features and
therefore we really had to stay
minimalistic
and later on i realized that and martin
told me that explicitly and we had
like fierce fights about that i wanted
to sneak some features into the language
and he pushed back and
it was really one of the best
experiences that they had it it's
it's very empowering so for you guys
though those who come from uh
lisp or those who who wrote
your own macro enabled languages like
nimrod which was presented yesterday at
elc it might be it might come as a
surprise
because macros are typically treated as
a core feature of the language
something that all other features have
to look up to and to
yeah okay but but here here it's here
it's a bit different
here macros have to stay minimalistic
and this is an important peculiar point
uh that empowered us to
to do some cool stuff really cool stuff
and i'm going to share that in
10 minutes so yeah this this is just a
quote from
one of the discussions that we had at
the mailing list from from martin
oderski
that it has to be absolutely has to be
simple
in order to get into scala so what's uh
what was the result of our discussions
and
uh what's uh what we put into 210
just a single language feature android
unique macros
that can only expand macro applications
well of course for
again for those of you who come from
this background this might
sound a bit meh well what he's talking
about come on
in lisp enclosure macros can do
everything so
well scala is sort of
well it's it's not like that it's not
like that
and uh oh yeah all those fancy things
that i was talking about quasi coding
hygiene we managed to
to work them around and this particular
workaround
uh that we put in place to to achieve
hygiene and quasi code and it's it's
kind of interesting
so i i'm going to show how it works
so here's actual scala code executable
into 10
that you can write so you write macros
as you would write normal functions so
well in scholarly define functions with
def
then put some type signatures but on the
right hand side where
usually your function body goes you just
write macro something
and this something is actually a
reference to the function that's going
to be executed at compile time
so this function takes abstract syntax
trees and stuff well
some representation of the program then
it generates some more code
and here's here's this thing that i was
talking about about quasi-coding and
hygiene
so usually macro-enabled languages they
they have a separate facility for
quasi-calls as we've seen in the
previous example
those fancy brackets that create code
templates
but here this this role is taken by by
re-efi
so refi is a function well actually it's
another macro
that's that essentially takes a code
template it generates a corresponding
abstract syntax tree
it also allows to to insert dynamic
parts into this template
by calls to this magic function splice
stuff like that and well as as you can
see
even here uh this minimalism
it had some some merits so essentially
since martin wasn't very impressed by
quasi-coating we had to
think a bit more and uh to come up with
with this elegant facility that uses
macros themselves
to create the quasi coding for quasi
coding tool
so at their core macros in 210 they are
unhygienic
but they can sort of bootstrap
themselves into being hygienic
using this using this rafi macro
and all that was quite interesting and
by that time
it was almost code freeze for for scala
to 10
and so we sort of started looking into
the future
with high hopes and this is another
quote from
from martin that's uh
for for quite a long time he he was
skeptical of macros
because of all of all the baggage that
they bring but this scheme it's
well it won't he's hard so
what what happened then after we
released macros in scholar 2.10 how did
people like it
actually even though even though there
are some problems that we're currently
fixing
and we're planning fixes for future
versions and
[Music]
the all in all it was much much more
popular than
we could even imagine a lot of
innovation in scala today is driven by
macros
and actually all talks about scala at
this conference they're powered by
macros to
to some extent so for instance the async
talk that that some of you have seen
today it's based on
a sink and the weight macros and the
talk about pickles and spores that's
going to to happen in this very room
right of the mine it's also based on
macros
so that's that was really unexpected
because
it's just a small language feature not
very powerful just expands
macro application uh method applications
and yet it has it has this interesting
effect so what's
what's the deal oh yeah right
i sort of glossed over that but i think
it's worth mentioning so
skeleton got released in in january this
year and in april
we had an internal meeting where we
decided to it was released in an
experimental capacity and during this
meeting we decided okay
macros are so useful that we got to put
them in the language
so we decided to figure out some some
subset of macros
some non-experimental thing that we can
rely on i'll talk about that later
and puts into some of the future
versions of the language
so what's the reason for for that
why did macros work and
our hypothesis is that essentially
for micro users it does it doesn't make
much difference uh
whether they use normal methods or or
macros they just don't notice that
and by a lucky coincidence a lot of
features in scala are really a lot of
features
they get the sugar to method calls and
this is where macros can hijack and can
literally empower these features to do
something something completely new
so as you see here here's a big list of
things
that are implemented with method calls i
think this is quite a cute feature of
scala
and probably this list isn't complete
it's
intentionally incomplete but all that
all that can benefit from compile-time
powers that are brought by macros
so our experience was uh to some extent
documented in
first in a workshop paper let our powers
combine
and also in my talk
in tel aviv in july so
you're you're welcome to take a look for
for more details there are a lot of
examples there
how how macros changed this or that
language feature and how that interplay
allowed people to solve problems that
were unreached unreachable before
and here i'll just i'll just give a
couple
couple of the most impressive examples
so first of all speaking of async
and speaking of this how macros feel
like normal methods
so this is an example of how
how one would do asynchronous
programming in scala in functional style
so you have futures and then you have
this methods flat map and map that that
are sort of
combinators that work on futures and
they allow these features to compose
so you do flat map map you you extract
results of futures into temporary
variables essentially when you write
disclosures
which are parameters to flat map and
everything's cool
but well as as you as you might agree
this is this is quite inscrutable and
imagine what if this grows
10 times for example so with macros we
can
we can sort of turn this around and we
can just use
async as a macro that will orchestrate
this transformation of synchronous code
to
asynchronous one and with the weight we
can mark
the asynchronity that we want to bring
in into the code
but the best thing that for the user it
doesn't feel like
like a compiler extension which is which
it
is and it doesn't feel like a new
language feature so we didn't
actually have we didn't actually have to
put this into the compiler
how philip said we we don't have to
implement this as a as another
phase in the compiler pipeline this is
just a macro this is just a library
and well for instance if asynchronous
programming it
becomes not fancy goes out of fashion
well no problem we don't have fisher
creep in the language
we just deprecate this library no
problem
so this is one of the examples why why
macros uh
sort of seamlessly uh
feel seamless in scala so another
example is uh
is one of the promised interactions with
other language features
so string interpolations and strings in
general
so strings are perceived as something
bad and untyped
you know there's this this expression
extremely typed programming you know
but actually with macros they don't have
to be they don't have to be like that
so so here we have this f string
interpolator
uh that's uh that essentially implements
printf
in a statically typed manner so at
compile time if you
if you misspecify the modifiers or if
you splice
some type incorrect things you will you
will get a compile-time error
and that all thanks to macros and here's
how it works
so actually as i said a lot of features
in scala get de-sugared into method
calls and string interpolation is no
exception
so when the compiler sees this f quotes
something it distributes it into into a
call to an extension method called f
on string context so here we have this
implicit class blah blah you can you can
gloss over
that i mean this is just a way of in
scala to declare extension methods
so and the main the main point here
that f f can be a normal method and then
everything will be processed at
at runtime but f can also be a macro
that inserts
type descriptions in strategic places
and then this type of
encryptions will make compiler uh i will
make compiler emit errors
if you if you get the types wrong
and the next example is uh
is another way how to how to make this
feature
play nicely so remember quasi calls and
remember this this tension that we had
that we couldn't put them into
into the language and that and thus we
had to come up with refi
well refi doesn't uh didn't work quite
well
it it requires its arguments to be
statically typed that
is if i want to write some some code
template that i later want to use in a
macro
with rafi i must have this templates
type check so it cannot contain free
variables for instance
and therefore if i have a huge template
and then i want to factor it out into
this this and this function
i cannot do that with refi because when
i factor
when i cut templates these parts they
might not make sense
in isolation without other parts
so back to quasi quotes classical solve
this this problem because they don't
care about
types and this this has proven to be
quite useful in
in well macro development
but now again string interpolation with
string
interpolation you can embed the
arbitrary languages into scala
and then you can and with macros you can
process them at compile time
so well sure you can just embed scala
into scala because i really like scala
and yeah this is how it worked so so
this
this this is one of the examples of how
minimalism of
scala's macro system actually paid off
and actually brought some something
really interesting and unexpected
now i i have one more example and
i don't know how to approach it because
that's my favorite feature of scala
really
people oh my god so implicit
maybe you've heard of it maybe not i'll
just give a
a quick quick introduction to implicits
so say
we're building a serialization library
and this civilization library
it will be based on this function called
piccol that takes this
takes this argument that it wants to
serialize
and then we want we want to make this
function extensible so therefore we
we use type classes to
to pull the the moving parts away from
the function so the
user can configure all this stuff
and so we create the specular type class
that has the pickle method and then then
user can can implement this speaking
strategies
so for example we know how to pickle and
ins most likely we'll just take this
binary array and then
write an integer into it or if it's not
a binary array if it's json
we can do some other strategy and well
here you can see how how this
extensibility works
so user has almost complete control over
over what can be what can be serialized
and how
and then thanks to implicits we actually
don't have to we actually don't have to
provide this
implicit parameter uh scala compiler is
going to figure it out for for
for ourselves so if you declare a
pickler for int with this implicit
keyword
then scala is going to think oh okay i
need i i need a pickler of integer
and here it is marked as implicit cool i
just
i just put it into that call and if we
try to pickle something unsupported then
then we get this aesthetic error so
scala will say
oh my god i i don't know how to pick a
string
and that's well that's quite cool that
gives you some sense of security and
that's what being stated typed is about
so speaking of this implicits and how it
works with serialization
the bad thing about implicits and type
classes in general is that you actually
have to implement them
right so for instance if you have
have some data type well then you
for instance this person then you have
to say okay i serialize this field and
that field and i put this into a picot
and all that's fine and unless you have
100 of these persons
in your program that's that's definitely
not cool so here's how macros can help
and here's how they improve the pawn
state of the art and
their libraries already in the wild that
do this
so see all this boilerplate that you
have to write yourself
you can generate it with a macro
so and it will it will be completely
equivalent to this code
so this code and that code well they're
going to be the same
so there are ways to to fight with
boilerplates using some advanced type
level techniques
and that's fine but some of these ways
they have performance problems
but macros they don't have this problem
because the code that ends up in byte
code
it's exactly the same as if you've
written it yourself so it's going to
have
excellent performance so hey macros are
quite cool right
but it's it's not it's it's not it yet
so the coolest thing about macros is
again
interaction with other language features
and how they map onto this method calls
so apparently as you can see you can
declare well here you can only see
valves implicit valves but you can you
can declare
methods as implicits so you can say
implicit therefore something
and if you declare such a macro as such
a method as a macro
then you don't have to write this code
at all
so instead of writing this this line 100
times for
all the classes in your program you just
write
this implementation once and forget
about civilization forever
you you don't care anymore so how it
works just just a brief walkthrough for
for those of you who don't know how um
gleasons and scala work
so as we've seen before compile when
compiler needs uh
to to resolve some some implicit
parameter in a call to a function
it it goes through through the lexical
scope and it sees what's declared there
with with the implicit flag and then it
tries to match it with tile with the
expected type and stuff
but actually it's a bit more complicated
because
implicit scope it transcends lexical
scope and for one it's
uh the compiler also looks into some
special places
say as for instance this companion
object of of
the pickler type class and when we put
when we put this macro into the
companion object
then the user of our macro he or she
won't have to import anything at all so
it will just work
and no one will notice anything just
just like this
so you write a normal invocation of a
pickle function
and then compiler finds this implicit
it's a macro
it clicks it expands and as you see here
everything happens without without any
user involvement so this topic is much
more elaborated than i presented here in
such a funny style and
you can google my talk applied
materialization in scala for more
details
it's uh it's a bit more deep
you can also materialize functional
dependencies
and you can also do other cool stuff you
can also connect to
to type level techniques all this is
quite interesting so
and uh okay what we have here
all right so this implicits as i
mentioned before implicits are my
favorite feature of scala
because they they sort of connect the
realm of types
and the realm of terms so just by
specifying a type
you can ask the compiler to to provide
you a value of the type
and this is where this connection goes
and when you multiply that by
by some restricted form of dependent
typing that scholar supports
things become very interesting
and well as i mentioned before this year
talks about scala are they powered by
macros to this or that extent
and you might want to to attend them and
see how how macros help in this or that
case
so this is just a fun quote it was quite
quite cute to to
to go through through my older
presentations and
this is a quote from from an early
design sketch when i was having fun
thinking of macro depths macro types
macro packages and things
but implicit snow in places implicit
macros that would be really too much
and this is a good illustration of how
how macros how many surprises macros
really brought
into into development of scala and
how powerful this small idea of just of
of just macros that expand method calls
how powerful it ended up being
thanks to scala being so rich and
interesting
uh well that's uh that's probably it uh
for the examples of
why macros worked and just to recap
macros are cool because uh
because they really use people's
intuition about existing scala features
and macro users they don't even they
don't even have to realize that they're
using macros
they just use normal features and these
features get transformed they get they
become better thanks to macros
and uh because because of this uh design
design thing with scala that a lot of
language features actually map onto
on the method calls we get something
really interesting here
now let's take a look into the future
into the stuff that's
that's that i'm experimenting with
so after
after the after death macros were
included in the scala to 10 and after we
had this code freeze and stuff
of course i realized that macros are
missing some features so for instance
with macros you cannot generate new
members in public classes something that
well these programmers would take for
granted
well sure you don't have classes but but
you can do this stuff
essentially essentially the same stuff
and so what's what's
the problem with macros with death
macros in 210
well the problem is that they cannot
affect bindings in
in almost any capacity so
the first aspect of this problem is that
you cannot pass just the random stuff
into macros it won't work because
macros want to type check their
arguments before the expansion takes
place
so this is this is the this is the
question that i get from from all these
folks okay can you implement lambda with
your macros oh no you can't oh
but then literally in this bootcamp so
yeah and
yeah that's right in 210 that's
impossible
the second thing the the same uh the
second manifestation of the problem is
is that
we cannot generate new classes and put
them into some visible places so since
macros are type checked as expressions
all definitions they stay local so i can
generate everything
all the things that they want but they
will stay local to this block and no one
will be able to see them well
actually actually that's not true but
that's that's a topic for another talk
so as i mentioned after after 210 ship
has sailed i
i set out to to fix this injustice to
bring us
to the same level as lisp
and then establish this macro paradise
a github repo or experiment with random
stuff and that
everyone can use so first it was a scala
fork now it's a compiler plugin so
actually in scholar to 10 you can
you can use this compiler plugin and
well
you can you can use all these fancy new
developments in your production projects
just a single compiler plugin and you're
all set
so well and then and then
there were these three macro flavors
that they wanted to implement
untyped macros type macros macro
annotations
so let's let's see what what that
implies so on type macros they solve
this this lambda problem
so now i can finally say okay at least
folks
in scala macros are rich enough to do
that no problem
so essentially instead of instead of
type specification
in the signature of a macro you just you
just write an underscore
and and well that's it and then macros
won't bother you with type shaking
the second feature is type macros so def
macros they expand terms macro calls
but it also would be fun to expand types
so here we we extend some some class
or so we think but actually it's it's a
type macro so this type macro it can
generate
some some publicly visible synthetic
class and then you can inherit from it
and then you get all the members in that
synthetic class okay that solves the
problem of type providers for instance
high f sharp also we have macro
notations
so def macros expand terms type macros
expand types
and macro notations they expand
definitions so you put
just just a simple annotation on your
definition
and then it gets expanded and
since since scala actually has first
class modules
you can use that to implement type
providers as well
well again i type providers are
more than just uh just generating some
boilerplate
type providers also support this erase
type generation and this is this is
quite interesting and cool
this can be emulated by by scala macros
as well
to some extent but i i won't go into
details they're quite hairy
so so we see this these new macro
flavors that fix all the problems that
death macros have
so what's what what next
actually we have we have this metaphor
that if you if you have uh
if you can can hide behavior of the
macro behind
its type signature so if you can
say that a macro is essentially
equivalent to a method with this
signature
then it's a black box macro because it's
implementation it can be treated as a
black box
but if you cannot do that so for
instance in the case of
macro annotations you cannot write a
signature in scala's type system for
that that's a white box macro
so macros in 210 they're black box well
to some extent and all these new things
there white box
so white box macros how cool are they do
people like them
well actually actually no
not really so sure boilerplate
generation
where in type provider fashion it's it's
cool
and a lot of people want it but but the
rest
not much all the stuff that i'm talking
about
it was implementing around half a year
ago maybe more
and by now i i don't know of a lot of
really nice use cases for that and
ironically enough
all the uses for untyped macros they
were actually driven by the
by the desire to to extend scala's type
system so if scala type system was
powerful enough
for example if it had kind polymorphism
people wouldn't even need this untyped
macros in that particular use case
so this is fun and and why why why it is
like that
so our hypothesis is that in in scala
people are really used to
to working with types and thinking with
types and it's considered to be
a super awesome form of hackery to come
up with some
type level solution that's
on one hand and on the other hand
well you don't in scala you don't have
you don't have a lot of language
features that work on definition level
so sure you can write definitions but
you there there's not not many ways
of abstracting our definitions so
there's there are no synergies to
exploit
unlike it was in the case of death
macros
so that's one of one explanation that
they have and another one
is that well when you write white box
macros
actually you you might end up in a
situation when you produce some code
that's not scala anymore
i mean that doesn't feel like scala so
as i'm running out of time so how much
time do i have
okay so just almost five minutes
so let's just quickly see this example
and how it works
so say we have we have a need to
represent enumerations in our scala code
so we need to generate all this
boilerplate right for
for four days of week and so we need to
have some singletons that represent
these days of week
and then the single tones they actually
have to be instances of some class and
this
and this class has to override two
strings so that so to get pretty
printing and
all this good stuff right of course we
don't want to write this by hand
and therefore let's just take one of the
tools that we've seen one of the white
bus macros
macro annotations and let's just
implement it like that
so we put this macro annotation onto
some nice
object that that represents this
enumeration values
in in some form of a dsl and then this
this macro notation it will take the
guts of this object so so
uh these expressions that that you can
write freely inside an object they they
get lifted into a constructor
and then it will it will seem to that
constructor it will
figure out all these names that we
provided and then it will generate
all the boilerplate that we want
everything cool and everything so
concise and nice until
until you scrutinize this a bit more
closely
so first of all it doesn't feel like
scala you just write some stuff
it has any identifiers whatever that
means some
just some identifiers and then they're
they're not even declared anywhere
so for instance if you declare a method
called monday outside
is this monday going to correspond to
that monday or
whatever that would mean so this is this
is what i meant when i when i said that
white box macros might be too powerful
because they can distort scala code
in into ways that that don't map on
people into people's intuition
about how scala code should work and
here's when when people on the mailing
list started discussing
the stuff quite quickly another another
proposal has arisen
so here you just try you just write
these values you you don't provide this
boilerplate but you say that these are
normal values
and for for everyone who reads this code
it should be quite natural that
this what's what will be generated by a
macro
after all after
after macro expansion finishes so this
is
this is the tension between the power of
macros
and the spirit of scala
and this is something that that we're
currently exploring macro paradise
and this is how we try to
to combine both both the tradition of
scala
and tradition of lisp into ultimate
macros
so just uh just to summarize what what
what i talked about so first macro
started as
a fun project but then really industrial
drive for meta programming it
it put it into a scalar release it
happened so fast and
it felt really great macros are cool
let's do
more macros and more languages and
then macros worked out really well
because of this
because of because they feel just just a
part of scala just like a part of scala
and because a lot of features in scala
they actually map onto
onto those macros and this brings a lot
of interesting
interactions so when i put when i put
these slides online
you can take a look at the paper and the
talk that they refer to
you can see much more examples of how
macros interact with other language
features
and then while we while we were trying
to to figure out
what works and what does not we came we
came up with this concept of black box
and white box macros
and now we're trying to to marry this
with scala
so that it can get the best macros
possible
thanks for your attention
you